Malcolm Gladwell is the author of five
minar tonnes bestsellers including the
tipping point and david-and-goliath his
narrative podcast series pana please
revisionist history is back for its
third season the show explores events
and ideas from the past that are often
overlooked or misunderstood it is number
one in Apple's podcast rankings the
longtime New Yorker writer is now
sharing his skills with everyone
his first online writing course is now
available through master class this
preview clip Gladwell discusses creating
suspense in nonfiction narratives are
about the resolution of problems that's
what a narrative is its I set up a
certain kinds of things and me and then
I solve all the little questions I
answer all the questions you have in
your mind with suspense there's certain
questions I don't answer and so your
natural reaction as a reader is wait why
right so there's no reason why suspense
should be specific to movies or
television shows or fiction you can do
exactly the same thing in a work of
nonfiction you can and without further
ado no suspense here Malcolm Gladwell at
the table great to have you here to be
here so why did you decide to share it
in this way your experiences I just
thought it'd be fun and also I think
that in a everything in the media world
is is is exploding and changing so
quickly that I think if you're a writer
you have to start exploring other ways
of reaching your audience that's why I
do the podcast and that's why I wanted
to do masterclass just because I don't
think you can if I only write books I
feel I'll I'll lose contact with a large
portion of the population what did you
learn by being intentional and thinking
about how to teach writing what did you
learn about or did you learn anything
about your own process and your own
writing with funny I never I've never
kind of reflected about it before you do
so now I've never thought about mine I
never thought people say well do you
have a process and I would say I've
never thought about I just have do it so
for the master class I actually sat down
and as I prepared for doing it I thought
about well how do I approach the task of
writing and
so it was a really an interesting kind
of moment it's like being on the the
couch at this rate that's at the shrink
you know you sort of get a window into
your own mind for the first time do you
worry about sharing your tips that
someone will try to copy your style or
do you just say there's only one Malcolm
well I wouldn't think I would have done
that when I was 25
it would not I'm now I'm so old Gail it
doesn't matter you know people can copy
me it's fine but what does revisionist
history I love the tagline things that
are overlooked and misunderstood what
does that give you that writing doesn't
you're a best-selling author what do you
get from the podcast that you don't get
from your books well I get there's
things you can do with sound yes that
are so one of the podcast episodes
that's coming up I have an interview
with I went to Nashville and I
interviewed Jack White and then this
extraordinary singer named Casey Bowles
and the you know Jack White was sitting
as far away from me as you are and I'm
right there and you and you get to
listen along as he played so he plays
Elvis songs for me and it's just this
incredible intimacy and he never he very
rarely gives interviews so that had to
be very special amazing and is that the
key to podcast is that sense of intimacy
that you have with the audience and so
if that's the key then how as a person
creating it how do you play with that
and where you wouldn't with writing or I
could explore like in the episode that
came out last week which was a piece
about football and my increasing
discomfort with risks and costs of
football and it's all about a family who
lost his son to football because he was
diagnosed with CTE after and took his
own life yes and you know the there's
something we could do with the podcast
that we could I couldn't do on the page
which is I'm sitting in the room with
the with the mom the dad and brother and
the sister-in-law and kids and the dog
and it's all happening all around you
and it's just that's what makes it
moving and powerful that was a
heartbreaking story actually and you
actually sort of call you pen on the
carpet too because it doesn't seem that
they have taken steps to do anything
about it I want to talk about the you
call it a shaggy dog story first what is
a shaggy dog story
something he made up no no shaggy-dog
story my father is English and the
English love shaggy dog stories they are
long pointless long detailed stories
with excessive narration with a
pointless punchline yes and you set it
up with the next story about semicolon I
don't mean to be insulting but at the
end I go I think this was a shaggy job I
love us love shaggy dog stories I'm
gonna stand up for them right now I will
deny that it was a shaggy dog story no
it looked like a shaggy dog story but
that we talked about the first episode
shaggy and it was it's a long whole area
story about the semicolon semicolons in
the Constitution and how there's a huge
political question that could be
resolved if you interpret a semicolon in
a specific part of the Khans in a
certain way and so I go and I sit down
with Mary Norris who is a copy writer an
old copy editor from the old copy editor
a brilliant copy over from The New
Yorker and also this incredibly
hilarious law school professor named
Michael Stokes Paulson and we just have
fun with this phrase and then we talk
about oh my god if the semicolon is a
certain way then American politics could
change overnight I'm not gonna give away
that yes please don't yes there are lots
of a lot of suspense there it was a lot
of this it was very extensive you see
the writing process there are lots of
little suspense little teases in the
structure so you get the right writing
lessons - I'm thinking Malcolm you and I
have different ideas of hilarious enjoy
that no no no I didn't say I just said
you and I have different ideas of
hilarious but I highly highly highly
recommend the podcast and it's always
good to see you always you're not
excited - Malcolm Gladwell's season 3
provisioners history is available
wherever you like to get your podcast